hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
January 22nd 2023
how the [ __ ] are you it's a brand new
year man
um
oh [ __ ] uh Billy Boilermaker over
here feeling a lot better
thank you to modern medicine see it's
not all bad I'm not saying it's all good
not saying it's honest not saying it's
not fixed
I'm just saying man when you actually go
to a doctor rather than talking to your
friend or going on the internet they
seem to know what the [ __ ] they're doing
and sure you leave with a couple of
microchips in you and all of a sudden
you don't mind Joe Biden but you know
what your cough goes away
and in the end isn't it all about you as
the individual
huh as you go out and you buy more [ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] need that's made out
of plastic and then you stick it in the
blue bin for recycling knowing full well
they don't recycle that [ __ ] now and
full well it's going to end up in the
ocean but you know what we're not gonna
see it
you might stumble upon a video that
shows it
and the second you hear that sad music
you're like I don't want to watch this
I had a tough day man I don't want to
deal with where that [ __ ] hula hoop
went
right
so you put on another video epic fails
you know what I like watching
I like watching Asians
in Asia
in the motherland on [ __ ] scooters
with too much [ __ ] on them trying to get
down this first of all it's [ __ ]
amazing the amount of [ __ ] you can get
on a goddamn scooter and then literally
the speed that people will drive with
all of that [ __ ] are possibly four or
five passengers it's incredible it's
it's like Keystone Cops it's like a
silent movie comedy I'm into that
I'm into the people uh I go all around
the world for failures
if I want to see somebody in Australia
fail I'll watch [ __ ] uh jerk off
picks up poisonous snake
you know that's a fun genre I go to
America
I'm in America
you know and I'll tell you what rest of
the world I don't see failure
what I just see is a bunch of people
bunch of Heroes having
the the the the the the courage to
attempt something
all right England I see failure all over
I'm kidding
America what you got to go with there
skateboarding
you got to go with that you know
these [ __ ] tricks some of these kids
learn you know my daughter has been
watching ninja kids and some of the [ __ ]
that these kids do you know flipping
around they're basically like gymnet
gymnast mixed with like Ninja Warriors
and some of the stuff that they do
you're like how in the [ __ ] do you learn
how to do that and so he's like well you
know they [ __ ] jump into a foam pit
you know that's like those [ __ ] guys
on those motocross bikes motorcycles
right and they [ __ ] do like a goddamn
backflip on a bike hold on to the seat
pull a bike back underneath them and
then land
it's like how the [ __ ] do you learn how
to do that like oh you know they
practice in a foam pit yeah until they
don't
and then there's that first time you do
it
okay
no foam on this one man like I don't
know how the [ __ ] you do that you got to
be the first time you do that got to be
like [ __ ]
because it's not only coming around and
Landing it you got to land
on like the ramp and if you overshoot
the ramp you're gonna like dislocate
your spine
I don't know it's a it's a whole other
level you know there's a lot of older
people My Generation [ __ ] on younger
people because that's that's what you do
as an older person
and all you younger people who are
sitting there like hey man [ __ ] these
older people harsh in my mellow man
um did anybody ever say that by the way
I never heard that line until
um
I don't know I had an acting gig in like
the 90s
um that's also like like the the thing
about
um it's like when somebody writes it in
a script then people attribute it to the
actual
people you know
like for some reason
um I think I've talked about this before
God knows I've been talking to myself on
this [ __ ] thing
since 2007.
um so forgive me if I repeat a story
don't you love when people do that when
they're [ __ ] it up and then they put
the guilt of it on you that's what I
just did there that's what I just did
there
um
I forgot my story oh I know when they
[ __ ] uh
they they try to make it seem like
people in Boston said Wicked pissa
oh that's wicked pissing nobody ever
said that
they'd say he's wicked stupid
oh that's [ __ ] piss up but nobody
ever said Wicked pissa
that cat in the Harvard Yard is wicked
pissing you know they just try to
combine everything
um
I bet that's true with a lot of [ __ ] I
do know anytime
there's a hit movie about a specific
part
of the world whenever I go to tour there
um I do a stand up whenever let's tour
there Bill let's take it down a few
whenever I go there to tell my [ __ ]
jokes
at some Casino
somebody always has to come up to me be
like did you see the movie you know
basically about this place and I would
be like yes I did and they go yeah
nobody talks like that
we don't [ __ ] talk like that all
right
um
it's like all right well you kind of do
you know
I guess we kind of say Wicked pistol we
just don't say it together
but then they say it enough times and
then people will actually start doing it
I also noticed that
like I remember when like uh the Red Sox
won in 2004 and ESPN just kept saying
people in New England are not going to
know what to do you know because we lost
for almost 100 years they're not going
to know what to do and then sure enough
they start interviewing
[ __ ] people in Massachusetts of
course they're all on like fishing boats
you know because that's what you know
there's so many Lobster fishermen up
there I love it they always try to do
that too right and then they literally
start in and then people like I don't
know what to do
they literally just they they fed you
the [ __ ] line enough times
you watched it and then you [ __ ] said
it
and you never noticed
you never noticed like I wasn't saying
that they said that I was saying it and
then when they put the camera on my face
I said what they said I was gonna say
how do you not do that and then you
don't feel like a [ __ ] you don't feel
dirty
um speaking of dirty let's talk about
the filthy NFL the more I watch this
[ __ ] the more I watch the NFL uh uh
#gamble on it
um the more I'm starting to get the NBA
in the 2000s Vibes when I would be
watching the NBA and I was telling all
my [ __ ] friends this [ __ ] is fixed
I'm telling you this shaven points to
something [ __ ] going on here and
everybody's ah Billy's got his [ __ ]
tinfoil hat on right and then they find
up a mob they find a mobbed up ref they
do the classic Oswald thing ah it was
just him he did the whole [ __ ] thing
and then years later they do one of
those [ __ ]
you know and ones or whatever the [ __ ]
it was called on Netflix
uh it wasn't called Land one they did a
thing on the and one
um
I forgot what the name of the series was
it was basically Netflix's 30 for 30 and
they showed like the corruption was the
front office a bunch of other [ __ ]
refs and they just put it on that
Donahue guy I'm getting those vibes on
the NFL now granted it is because I'm
gambling and I'm a [ __ ] sore loser so
take some of this with a grain of
[ __ ] salt can we put the goddamn
toilet away where they belong
Jesus Christ it drives me [ __ ] nuts
here
you know you get all of these [ __ ]
toys and they just
leave them all over the place anyway
um
if I see one more [ __ ] game
I like this like I'm making this threat
like what Bill you're gonna stop
watching and start reading of course
you're not this is bread and circus and
you're [ __ ] eating it up every
goddamn week this is what happens every
[ __ ] goddamn game that if I bet the
favorite
if I'm laying points on the [ __ ]
affair
the other team cannot move the [ __ ]
ball and this is something I know I keep
talking about this but I don't give a
[ __ ]
if I see one more [ __ ] offense that
cannot move a ball for an entire [ __ ]
half
and all of a sudden they get the ball
back and there's a minute 48 left what
are the announcers always say
it's plenty of time left
maybe they left too much time what do
you mean they left too much time
they've been playing almost 30 minutes
of football they haven't been able to
score a [ __ ] point and then for some
[ __ ] reason when there's two minutes
left all of a sudden there's too much
time
the first 28 minutes nothing [ __ ]
happens
in the second half
it's it's like
they cue the announcers the announcers
say plenty of time left
but did they leave too much time I'll
tell you right now they got three
timeouts that's plenty of time to move
the ball down the field it's like based
on what
they haven't been able to move the
[ __ ] ball since the second quarter
they've had 28 [ __ ] minutes to move
the [ __ ] ball in the second half and
they haven't been able to and the second
one of those wavy-haired [ __ ] up in the
booth goes there's plenty of [ __ ]
time left the other [ __ ] they turn
into [ __ ] Joe Montana
to John Taylor 15 yards 11 yards seven
yards 22 yards they're a field goal
right
every [ __ ] game not every game but so
many [ __ ] games become these [ __ ]
heart attack games
and the other team just concedes after
playing defense for 28 minutes we're now
just going to give them a [ __ ] score
I watched that with the Dolphins game
Dolphins weren't doing [ __ ] they had a
backup [ __ ] quarterback
you know
I'm laying a [ __ ] point and a half
we're up by like [ __ ] eight or nine
and I'm just like oh here we go they're
just going to give him a touchdown big
Bank boom [ __ ] touchdown
right right down the [ __ ] field and
now I have to sit there my [ __ ]
puckered
open Mac Jones and them can go into the
victory formation and get me out of the
[ __ ] game the only other game I
watched the end of the game I watched
the [ __ ] Ravens versus the Steelers
13-9 nobody scored nobody's scoring
minute left [ __ ] Steelers bang bang
boom [ __ ] touchdown
right down the [ __ ] field
week after week game after game you just
see the [ __ ] prevent defense
Actually I don't even think the Ravens
were in that I don't know that might
have been a legit one I'm not saying
they all are but that stupid prevent
defense it yeah I I'm telling you I I am
convinced of this it comes from the
marketing department of the NFL which I
learned this week
okay those [ __ ] are not registered as a
sports League they're registered as an
entertainment League
all right
I mean that's a Federal Reserve [ __ ]
right there
you can't you can't
convince me otherwise I 100 percent
believe I believe the Jumbotron is used
for crowd control now
and I'm sure that their marketing
department be like Well everybody's on
their screens uh we just don't got what
God forbid we [ __ ] let him sit there
and talk about the goddamn game every
second there's a stop at your [ __ ]
play that Jumbotron comes on you know
where's the where's the peanut huh which
which car is underneath and everybody's
sister going hey foreign
I don't know maybe it prevents drunks
from beating the [ __ ] out of each other
but I actually you know now that I've
just been this whiny [ __ ] confident
like the last six minutes I actually
think that what really all of this is
um
is the ramblings of a man who's now you
know in his mid 50s and the fascinating
thing about
being in your mid 50s
is that once you get to like 54 pushing
55 as I am capitalism is done with you
okay they have no more use for you and
the same way the game
um a player gets too old to play the
same way the game passes a coach by even
the greatest coaches if they hang around
too long everybody sees what they're
doing they break it down they steal it
you know
and then they'll literally become a
parody of himself
you know which I've never understood
that how you become a parody of yourself
it's like no you just know who I am at
this point
I guess that means you stopped growing
as an artist maybe that's what it means
I don't know what the [ __ ] it means but
all I know is you get to be my age
and you start doing this thing you're
like hey man like things aren't the way
they used to be and
you you do that for like 10 years
waiting for someone to give a [ __ ]
you know because in your head you still
feel like you're 20 and you think that
people care what you think and it takes
you if you're you're like me it takes
you a good 10 years to get out of your
ego to realize that you're just an old
man now and nobody cares what you have
to say
so that's where I am so I feel like I am
now going to I um
maybe go into semi-retirement
as a sports fan
which is great which is sort of like
mentally you know it's it's sort of the
uh um
I don't know what the mental version I
guess the hobby version
of becoming an empty nester
that day when your last kid moves out
and like you don't even know what the
[ __ ] to do with all of this free time
you know
so you probably get a dog
just pay way too much attention to it
you know to the point the dog actually
wish you left it at the pound
um
yeah I don't uh
I don't ever remember when I was a kid
them saying there's plenty of time left
with [ __ ] a minute 50 left there
wasn't plenty of time left it was like
they better get their [ __ ] asses
moving because there's no time left
there's not plenty of [ __ ] time left
with a minute 50. in a [ __ ] football
game if you haven't moved the [ __ ]
ball at all it's just the announcers are
either in on it or they [ __ ] know
that the other team's just gonna start
giving them like a 10 15 yard [ __ ]
cushion
they've watched enough game oh dude I
have so many [ __ ] conspiracies this
is another thing too I cannot [ __ ]
believe you know I still can't believe
everybody is like anybody [ __ ]
marijuana is legal I can't believe
Sports gambling is [ __ ] legal
like to the point that the leagues are
in on it
and that they don't feel like there's
any sort of conflict of [ __ ] interest
in the way that it's a corporation
and a corporation always has to make
more and more money the temptation
for a side deal with a [ __ ] Casino
I mean I'm calling that right now
sometime in the next 30 years they're
going to say [ __ ] 20 years prior to
this this [ __ ] went down on a you
know they'll do some 30 for 30.
on that [ __ ] I mean there's just no
[ __ ] and I I I'm jaded all right I've
been in the businesses show too long
I've never
gotten a business with anybody who
didn't have a [ __ ] side deal with
somebody else
you know and all you got to do is just
sit there across the table and let them
talk and you just see where they're
staring you
well I think this this thing have a good
home over here oh oh yeah what's your
Kickback every [ __ ] show you bring
over there the [ __ ] out of here you
think it's good over there it's good for
you it's good for you if it goes over
there right so you get a brand new
[ __ ] Delta 88
whatever your company [ __ ] car is
[Music]
um
anyway how about that college [ __ ]
football
playoffs
on uh on Saturday
TCU come on frogs versus Michigan
Wolverines with the greatest fight song
possibly in the world
I put up Hail to the Victor's Valiant
Hail to the co I would put that up
against any of those soccer songs
that they got to sing over there with
their scarves on they wear those scarves
to keep their voice box warm so they can
sink
that's what it is
that The Tenors and then the baritones
and all of that [ __ ]
and they sing all of those songs while
somebody rides roll around on the
[ __ ] ground pretending they actually
got hurt right I would put those songs
that song up against anything that the
[ __ ] crowds sing over in the Premier
League
all right
I'm just doing this because I want fans
of the Premier League send me your best
songs because they actually have some
good ones
there was that one player who never
scores
what the [ __ ] was this and whatever his
name was some something is on fire
you know something something was funny I
actually felt bad for the player anyway
let me get back to [ __ ] uh real
football American football played the
way it's supposed to play you pick the
[ __ ] but you use all of your limbs
foreign
you don't just use your hands to cover
your junk when somebody's trying to Bend
It Like Beckham
um
and I know you know this is this is part
of being an American okay part of being
an American is to do things differently
even if they make no sense like ignoring
the metric system
like why we ever abandon that is the
dumbest [ __ ] ever and the greatest
argument I've ever heard for the metric
system
is that water freezes at zero degrees
Celsius and 100 and it boils at 100
degrees and then you look at the
standard system that we're on and water
freezes at 32 degrees and boils at 212
degrees point something or other
it's zero and a hundred could it be in
could it be any [ __ ] easy or for us
Burger eating [ __ ] and we just not not
doing it
not [ __ ] donut not where not [ __ ]
listening to you not listening to Yo and
we're [ __ ] doing [ __ ] the hard way
um
anyway uh
I remember a long time ago this English
woman was trashing American football
she's like right bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we're in helmets and pads it's like lady
they die at like 50.
they commit suicide
huh
these soccer players have to do that at
the end we'll run around their little
[ __ ] shorts I don't think they do
maybe because they got all their [ __ ]
emotions out rolling around on the pitch
um TCU come on frogs frogs I actually
really enjoy soccer I'm just [ __ ]
with you guys
um
first is the Michigan Wolverines uh TCU
played an absolutely fantastic game and
they played as great a game as Michigan
played a terrible game I mean Michigan
just
I don't know they just I don't know what
they were doing
through two pick sixes
you know falling on your ass and letting
the [ __ ] quarterback run they just
really
dug a hole that was too deep to [ __ ]
crawl out of numerous times and somehow
they kept doing it it was a very
exciting game if you're into offense it
kind of reminded me of one of the worst
games I ever saw which was Kansas City
versus the Buffalo Bills last year in
the playoffs and I know you all you
[ __ ] idiots who grew up playing
Madden football thought that what you
were watching was a great football game
it was the worst football game I saw
since the Patriots Eagles Super Bowl
where I'm just sitting there like what
am I watching here how can these be two
teams playing for a [ __ ] Championship
when it's like there's not even a
defense on the field
um
you know I don't know maybe you like
when you want to go see a movie you just
want to see a car chase for 90 [ __ ]
minutes
um who knows and if you do I would
suggest watching the first uh Gone in 60
Seconds the original one with the final
45 minutes is a car chase which I'll
tell you was actually
wonderful so uh TCU I was nervous about
that game I mentioned it on anything
better with Paul verzi where
since tcu's program became a force to be
reckoned with
um
like 10 years ago
I've never seen them choke in a big game
until they blew their conference title
game
which for whatever reason didn't knock
him out of the playoffs I guess because
USC then had two losses somebody told me
the other day
that's why you USC got knocked out and
OSU got in but
um
I've never seen him blow a big game
other than that one I was shocked
and I missed the game whatever they did
they went for it or something like that
rather than playing for the overtime
um and I was just sitting there going
like what are the odds TCU
blows two big games in a row
um
that's what I was worried about but I
thought Michigan would run the ball and
um
basically
be controlling the clock
um but TCU man they were really [ __ ]
fast and I feel like Michigan because
they threw the pick six they just kind
of got
they started playing tcu's game
um also by the way once again you know
first [ __ ] drive fourth and goal
rather than kicking the [ __ ] field
goal Michigan [ __ ] goes for it
doesn't get it right
which not only do you come away with no
points you psychologically inflate the
other team and deflate yourself which
analytics does not take into
consideration in the third quarter they
go for a two-point conversion and they
don't [ __ ] get it
fourth quarter they score a touchdown go
for a two-point conversion they get it
and they get one of those four points
back that they left
just sitting there in the first and
second quarter and guess what they were
down by three points it should have been
a Thai [ __ ] game it's so [ __ ]
stupid you just sit there chasing your
your your fourth and goal and your
missed [ __ ] two-point conversion the
rest of the [ __ ] game it's the
dumbest [ __ ] ever but like I said
I'm 54 and a half
sliding into 55 capitalism is done with
me these entertainment leagues are done
with me
you know 611 nobody underneath yeah just
[ __ ] launched that three-pointer
plank it off the back don't worry get
back on defense it doesn't matter that
you missed and there was nobody
Underneath It doesn't [ __ ] matter
because the other team's gonna do it too
50 times a [ __ ] game
um
in the [ __ ] [ __ ] sitting in front
of me 50 [ __ ] times every time they
launch a three-pointer is going to put
three fingers up just just to let
everybody know that he knows that a
three-pointer was just attempted oh oh
am I in a [ __ ] mood
so TCU congratulations come on frogs are
in the championship game and then the
Georgia Bulldogs
went up against OSU everybody knew that
Georgia was going to win everybody knew
but everybody thought that OSU was going
to get absolutely stomped and they
didn't it turned out that they actually
should have won the game
but they uh they just made they made too
many [ __ ] mistakes that cornerback
falling down
and you know everybody's going to [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] field goal kicker
um
but a bunch of [ __ ] happened before then
that they shouldn't have got into that
position I was actually going out to a
New Year's party so there was a portion
of the game that I missed but um
as a Michigan fan I still have to give
it up to Ohio State the [ __ ] whining
[ __ ] who every year say that they
should be in the playoffs and then they
get their [ __ ] asses kicked finally
showed up and played a great game it was
a [ __ ] amazing game
um
that OSU should have won
they should have won the game and
unfortunately they didn't I feel bad for
that field goal kicker because most
people in life don't go after their
dreams
and if they do they don't get where they
want to be or don't feel like they get
the recognition
so uh when somebody misses a field goal
that becomes a way for them to just
[ __ ] like Focus all of their
disappointment on themselves onto this
person and just [ __ ] ruin that kid's
life which I hope people don't do
um anyway so now it's TCU come on frogs
versus Ohio State uh I'm sorry versus
Georgia that's how much I thought Ohio
State should have won that game I'm
saying that they won it
um that was an incredible [ __ ] game
um uh once again high scoring you know
I'm old I'm gonna stop bitching that
there's no defense in in [ __ ] Sports
anymore it's all right uh TCU Horned
Frogs versus the Georgia Bulldogs
um
I'm gonna go with TCU I'm betting TCU
I'm gonna try to go to the game see if I
can get [ __ ] tickets I was looking
for a hookup out here and everybody's
like oh yeah I'll look into it I'll look
into it I'm like can you look into it
before people know
what teams are going to be in it because
once people know then all the prices are
going to go through the [ __ ] roof
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll do
that I'll do that
never happened
um all right so it's the first 10 days
of the month you know what that means oh
Billy detox
Billy's not I don't I don't drink
anymore
all right I'm off the sugar I'm off
caffeine
uh
no recreational [ __ ] the occasional
hit of weed which I'm kind of psyched
like I'm kind of not into weed anymore
although uh you know New Year's Eve I
took too many hits or something and I
was just [ __ ] sitting there
going like I just I don't like this
like we to a certain point is great and
then once you go beyond it's like worse
than alcohol in a way
because alcohol you're like ah you don't
even know what you don't even know what
you're doing
whoever that is that I mean alcohol too
much alcohol is bad for people around
you too much weed is bad for you
I was just sitting there like
I couldn't say anything to anybody other
than like hey man what's going on Happy
New Year I just was just going like dude
I am like really high
I'm like too high right now and people
will laugh and go that's good that you
admitted it
you know rather than trying to ride it
out yeah I was like reaching out for
help I just sat at this [ __ ] table
for like the last 15 minutes of 2022.
you know when you're just sitting there
you're on the rocket ship going like all
right have we reached cruising altitude
uh I guess without still going up
[ __ ] Chuck Yeager
so um
which was not how I wanted to start the
[ __ ] year I'm I'm too [ __ ] old to
start the year feeling like [ __ ]
all right so
I don't know underrated going to bed at
9 30 on New Year's Eve you know you're
old nobody's [ __ ] you go to bed
if you're young by all means get out
there and have a good time put on your
[ __ ] hat and have a [ __ ] great
time but if you're me if you're me right
and Society is done with I'm sliding
into my Society is done with me years
and I gotta I'll be honest with you I'm
going to embrace it
you know what I mean I think I'm going
to start I think I'm gonna slowly enter
my putzing around town years I'm gonna
get myself a sweater
you know
I'm gonna do that thing you know old
people they walk down the street and all
of a sudden they just look at a
storefront they just stop and they start
looking at it
like reading this the sign or whatever
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they're
what are they remembering what it used
to be I remember you could show your
your eye once this Tower got rid of the
blacksmith it all went downhill
um
yeah I'm gonna put some around town
um I love doing these 10-day detoxes
though
um I will tell you I am going to smoke a
cigar today
because it is you know I'm gonna watch
the Winter Classic and I haven't had a
cigar in 11 days
so I'll Have a Cigar today but I'm not
going to have one
I mean I don't know when I'll have one
next I kind of really don't smoke
anymore which I really enjoy I probably
have I had two cigars in November and I
had three
kind of two and a half
in December which is [ __ ] great for
me because I used to have like 35
[Laughter]
.
so
um
yeah I kind of have it
like down like where it needs to be so
and uh and then my coffee drinking right
I absolutely you know fell in love with
coffee this past year
and like most things I fall in love with
I then do them too much
you know which is a good thing if it's
like going to the gym or playing drums
or you know
doing stand-up that's a good thing but
if it's a bad thing like coffee I start
doing you know what the [ __ ] I ended up
like when I come back after my 10-day
detox right
I'll get myself a cappuccino and I'm
like oh God this is [ __ ] delicious
and I just sit there and I sip it and I
enjoy it
and then like 15 days later
it becomes like an everyday thing and
what I do is I get a double espresso
and then I get a cappuccino to go right
and then I do that for like three days
in a row
and on the fourth day I wake up and I
just have this anxiety
and I walk around going like what the
[ __ ] is this it's just like you know
what it is Bill you you you're a [ __ ]
lunatic and you're drinking too much
coffee but then the first 10 days of the
month comes up and you know what happens
is my anxiety because of so much [ __ ]
caffeine that I put myself like a
[ __ ] idiot is I usually stop drinking
coffee two or three days before the end
of the month so I'm kind of going like
half the month
not drinking it
but
you know the way I drink coffee is why I
stopped drinking alcohol
because I I have this weird thing where
um
it's like I really think addiction is
this it's a spectrum
like it isn't either you are you aren't
I just have that thing if I'm doing it
I'm [ __ ] doing it but then I can just
stop
I don't have to get a sponsor and eat
donuts and smoke cigarettes and [ __ ]
tell my stories
in front of a bunch of other people you
know what I mean with yellow fingers and
brown teeth I don't need to do that I
can just on my own be like all right
I've had enough of that I'm doing this
too much just stop
I'm not gonna lie to you it does suck
for like three four days and then I'm
fine except for coffee
coffee I can just stop it and
and you know what it is it's the second
I stop the next day my old man nap comes
back because I don't have any caffeine
in me and once I take that old man nap
I'm like oh yeah
this is what life is supposed to feel
like
underrated an old man nap
and don't be if you're in your 20s and
you're feeling a nap don't fight it
give in to it take a [ __ ] nap it's
good for you when you're young you think
oh my God this means I'm old
or whatever it doesn't just listen to
your [ __ ] body just [ __ ] take a
[ __ ] nap it's the best
it's the best you wake up it's like it's
like a brand new day again
you know
and you're right as rain until Wheel of
Fortune comes on
at least at my age right around Wheel of
Fortune I start yawning and I start
looking at my watch
um
you know although that is one of the
best parts of the day for me
is from like five to eight thirty nine
o'clock every single day
I hang out with my kids
um five either five five thirty six
o'clock depends on how busy my day is I
spend that last like two two and a half
three hours with them and what I notice
about my kids is when we sit down to
watch like a movie they don't sit on the
couch as much as they sit on me they
literally climb on me
like
like I'm like I'm a [ __ ] jungle gym
and I I don't even notice it at this I'm
just sort of pushing them like down a
little bit off to the side and then they
end up back sitting on my my daughter
would really like sit on my [ __ ]
chest
like it's like I'm a chair
and I gotta be like dude you're not
little anymore can you get over there
and she thinks it's [ __ ] hilarious or
I'll be like laying on the couch
well you know you do that thing like you
look like you're in agony
because it's the middle of the day and
you're trying to take a nap so you put
your arm over your eyes
she will come running in the room and
jump on me knees first
just to hear me go ah and she thinks
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever
um
anyway
but uh I've been enjoying my time off
I've been spending all kinds of time
with my kids which is [ __ ] amazing
and
um
and yesterday I took my wife out for a
drive
New Year's
New Year's Day I guess I'm all confused
because the Rose Bowls today New Year's
Day and um
I took her out to Malibu one of my
favorite things to do she loves the
ocean it literally changes
her mood she was already in a good mood
she got to like an even better mood so
that's one of my New Year's resolutions
is to take my wife out to uh the beach
I'll do this like two more times and
then I'll forget and I'll get all
[ __ ] wound up with life
or whatever
I hope I don't though
um that was depressing wasn't it wasn't
that sad hey we got some great emails
this week um I got to remind you guys
Monday Morning podcast at gmail.com
that is
the uh that's the email
if you want to write in if you want to
give me [ __ ] if you want to do this what
should we do what shouldn't we have done
um oh by the way yeah I've been playing
a bunch of drums and uh Billy Bonzo foot
my my right foot is back to where it was
um I've been playing good times bad
times with the hi-hat going
faking those [ __ ] triplets I think
they I don't dare record myself but it
sounds pretty goddamn good for me you
know a Guitar Center Dad I think I'm
doing all right here
all right we're gonna do some reads here
oh by the way oh she's [ __ ] babbling
this week
you know it's [ __ ] underrated Kenny
Rogers
rest his soul
that son of a [ __ ] made some great
goddamn kitchen uh chicken didn't he
I [ __ ] up that joke um no his his uh
his music
I somehow stumbled on the gambler
which when I was a kid they just played
it way too many [ __ ] times
it was becoming country Stairway to
Heaven I was like if I hear that [ __ ]
stupid song One More goddamn time
you know
I used to play the song at weddings
just because everybody like knew the
[ __ ] song I'd be like a wedding you
got to know when to hold them
like what are we talking about here like
we're supposed to be acting like these
people are [ __ ]
gonna be together for the rest of their
life and you're playing The Gambler
no when to fold them
know when to have a side piece know when
to be loyal
you now the [ __ ] at your wife because
she doesn't take responsibility for any
other actions
but you put your feet to the fire
um all right
let's see here
I want to do the background on that
you got to know when to hold the window
holder
there's somebody in a [ __ ] Waffle
House going that was me
that was you what are you doing here in
the Waffle House I was a backup singer
they paid us once and that was it
all right let's do the [ __ ] reads
here for the week oh
oh look who it is it's old zip
code up
talk about some personal goals you have
for 2023 and the people you may need to
help
you achieve them and the people you may
need to help you achieve them uh I want
to bring my wife to the beach more this
year
and I'm going to need my wife to come
along with me or else what's the point
of me driving out to the beach
so that's why I called I use old zip
recruiter I'm five you know what do you
want for me uh dietitian eat healthier
therapists maintain mental I'm going
back to therapy definitely personal
trainer yeah I'm doing that
but I also want to eat healthy I used to
say and I'm is this what the kids call a
basic [ __ ]
um it's hard to find people who are so
good at what they do
um it's like if you're hiring how can
you find the best people for all the
different roles on your team easy easy
zip recruiter and right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
why zip
I'll tell you why because zip
uses its powerful matching technology to
find the right candidates for your job
see a candidate who be perfect for your
job sip recruiter makes it easier to
send them a personal invite
oh you got to slide to their DMS hey
baby I'd love to see you work in the
lumber yard uh so they're more likely to
apply zip yeah
also offers attention-grabbing labels
that speak to job flexibility like
remote training provided and more
um the copy just sort of ended there
well look if that interests you listen
if you got if you have a hole you're
trying to fill at your job
and you want the best hole filler go to
ziprecruiter.com
you'll be able to sift through all of
your top candidates
for once in your life you'll feel good
looking
right is this what it's like to be good
at sports and have a dimple in my chin
and a twinkle in my eye that's what
you're gonna feel like the high school
quarterback who's banging the best
cheerleader best looking cheerleader not
the best one the best looking
you youngsters will learn in life
there's a difference between best
looking and the best person
very rarely are they the same person
which for some reason wants me to give a
shout out to Barbara Walters rest in
peace
one of the greatest to ever do it
um
that really made me feel old when she
died even though she was in her 90s
because then I started watching all
these highlights of people she was
interviewing and not only is she dead
the person she's interviewing is dead
um all right policy genius everybody
um you know we all hope we never need
life insurance
well you're gonna [ __ ] need it
because you're gonna die someday but
mortgage payments child care and other
expenses don't disappear when you're
gone yeah you don't want your family
going to debtors prison since life
insurance typically gets more expensive
as we age Now's the Time to buy yeah it
is
get health insurance and life insurance
when you're young
that's what you need to do get Blue
Cross Blue Shield
when all your VI all your [ __ ] your
organs are brand new right
it's still a cream puff that's when you
get it you get a nice low [ __ ] rate
um
since life insurance typically gets more
expensive as we age Now's the Time to
buy policy genius gives you a smarter
way to find and buy the right coverage
for you and your family policy genius
was built to modernize the life
insurance industry the technology makes
it easy to compare life insurance quotes
from top country companies like AIG I
love how they're AIG weren't they that
comes from 2008 hang on a second we're
too big to fail all of a sudden they're
the good guys again this is like [ __ ]
Hulk Hogan
what color is his mustache or his beard
okay a i g 2008.
what went wrong at aigit is them
top companies
[ __ ] bastards they should all be
[ __ ] they should have thrown them in
the ocean AIG and Prudential in just a
few clicks to find your lowest price
with policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just 17
per month for five hundred thousand
dollars of coverage and policy genius
has licensed agents who can help you
find options that offer coverage in as
little as a week and avoid unnecessary
medical exams they're not incentivized
to recommend one insurer over another so
you can trust their guidance there are
no added fees and your personal
information is private no wonder they
have thousands of five star reviews on
Google and trustpilot your loved ones
deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to find it and buy
it
had the policy genius or click the link
in the description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's policygenius.com
um
look at that I don't even have like the
slash Burr slash freckles slash slash
redheaded [ __ ]
how do I how do I even know
if I'm gonna get I want my credit
um
all right here's something that somebody
wrote In which I find hard to believe I
hope it's true said Quentin Tarantino
story shout out
hey Billy Once Upon a Time
I'm not sure if anyone told you this yet
but Quentin Tarantino recalled a story
you told about heckling Don Rickles
it was very cool to see my favorite
director bringing up my favorite
comic
uh can you send me the link to that
because if that actually happened I will
listen to that on a loop
walking around with my [ __ ] Sony
Walkman
I'll put that on cassette tape
um
not only is Quentin Tarantino one of my
favorite directors of all time he's my
he he is my favorite
um um movie owner whatever you call it
the movie house
the New Beverly Cinema
I [ __ ] love that place I wish they
all you know what was the last you know
what I love about that place you go in
there and you're like whoever owns this
Loves Movies you don't feel that when
you go to the goddamn mall and it just
you know it just looks like you know
like a comedy club chain where they got
the same 10 [ __ ] headshots in every
location
up on the goddamn wall
um that's another New Year's resolution
I'm going to more [ __ ] movies this
year I'm gonna go see Babylon I don't
give a [ __ ] that people said you know it
was too long or whatever at least it's a
movie for an adult
I'm seeing that [ __ ] movie this week
look at me I'm doing things in 2023
Somebody's gotta [ __ ] go and show up
so that movie makes some goddamn money I
mean the rest of our lives every goddamn
movie gonna be a Pixar movie or a
superhero movie
but shout out to the superhero movie
fans I mean at least they're going right
um anyway that would be incredible if
that's actually a true story I I doubt
that it is a true story because I would
think that someone else would have heard
it and let me know other than a listener
um but I think most of you could give a
[ __ ] if he gave me a shout out or not
what you really want to know is the
story of me heckling Don Rickles
um
all right I've told this a million times
I was I was pretty hammered I'm not
gonna lie to you and I went to go see
him rest his soul
out in uh Palm Desert and I wanted to
meet him and someone was trying to hook
it up and it didn't [ __ ] happen so
I wanted to have an interaction with
them so I waited for his encore
and when he came out there he's just
playing with the crowd he was just
[ __ ] around he was doing a Victory
lap
so I just kept yelling out I just kept
going Daddy
right and he's doing his jokes
everything's going good and then I'd go
Donny
I didn't either two or three times
and on the third time he just looked at
my general direction you know with that
[ __ ] smile that he did that he was
really saying go [ __ ] yourself he just
goes yeah I know my name and I was with
bartnick and he looked at me and he
smiled and I was like that's it I had my
interaction with them
um
but that's when I was oh Billy booze
back oh you know
Billy sober [ __ ] wouldn't do that and
then would [ __ ] about sports every
[ __ ] week
um all right bags
dear Billy bag balls I'm hearing you
talk about the amount of bags your wife
has prompt has prompted me to write in
about an Instagram account I follow my
wife doesn't have a bunch of bags I just
[ __ ] all right she deserves the bags
because she [ __ ] is married to me and
I'm not just saying that it's [ __ ]
true
um you know what I mean
I mean I have like [ __ ] four guitars
and I suck on all of them
why do I have four guitars
you know why did I keep buying guitars
because I liked them you know so
whatever she's into bags anyway this
guy's his handle is at Tanner dot
leather steam oh you know what speaking
of that
on my last [ __ ] stop of the tour
or maybe I think I was in Austin some
company that makes custom leather
jackets gave me a leather jacket I have
to give them a shout out I was going to
give them a shout out on Instagram and I
just got nervous because I couldn't
figure out if it was the right one or
not the next podcast I promised them I'm
just going to read the label it is the
softest most comfortable leather jacket
I have ever worn I absolutely [ __ ]
love it and
they just made it for me no you know I
never met them they didn't measure me or
anything and it still fits like a glove
like a glove
um anyway his handle is at Tanner
t-a-n-n-e-r dot leatherstein he's an he
is an expert on leather and the quality
of leather products I'm already
following this person this is amazing uh
what he does is by different designer
bags and reveals the actual quality of
the craftsmanship and the material
he cuts them open strips them down and
uses chemicals to remove the textured
coating
oh my God I I could watch this like a TV
show with my wife
uh to let consumers know if their
expensive item is really well made or
not sometimes they'll give it a thumbs
up and agree that it's a well-made item
or it'll expose super cheap quality
holy [ __ ]
if I was this guy I would actually get a
security team
that's how you get yourself [ __ ]
whacked
um
I'll definitely be watching those videos
with my wife that I I mentioned by the
way that um the new show me and my wife
are watching is the um
George and Tammy show
um
on Showtime about uh George Jones
and uh Tammy Wynette
um let me get the cast here I want to
give shout out to all of these people
um
Michael Shannon
and Jessica oh God Chastain is that he
said absolutely
[ __ ]
crushing it
um and I don't know who did like the uh
the Wardrobe on it or anything like that
or the sets or anything like when they
get
um when they played Vegas they like
rebuilt like a Vegas showroom I so wish
the showrooms still looked like that
um
Katie Mixon Steve Zahn Walter Goggins
I love how they did the way he looks in
that thing is amazing
um
it's just an incredible [ __ ] show the
performances are amazing and it's so
good I actually know
the story and I'm still rooting for them
knowing full well what happens you know
what I mean
it's kind of like every time I watch
Evel Knievel jump up the fountain at
[ __ ] Caesars you're still kind of
hoping he makes it
um anyway but by the way I mean this I
usually don't get stuff like this if you
guys know cool [ __ ] like this to follow
um
I love like
anything where people are uh
you know making things themselves or or
exposing these corporations as far as
like all right is it worth all of this
money
anything you know
like clothing related
uh
car related truck motorcycle any of that
[ __ ] speaking of which oh Billy's F250
should be showing up
I hope so do you know I went down to the
[ __ ] Ford dealership because I you
know I I gotta like rent somebody's
garage to uh put this thing in you know
clear sign that I bought something that
I don't need which is you know that's my
God damn it right
um
and I'm trying to [ __ ] you know I got
the regular cab which is rare not like
they don't usually just make the Crew
Cabs or the super caps so I went down to
the Ford dealership because usually
they'll have one random like F-150
[ __ ] work truck down there with a
regular cab and lo and behold they did
so I got a Salesman to come out there
and help me measure the thing to see how
long it was it was just a little over 19
feet which
basically agreed with the information
that I found on the internet but you
know it's the internet you can upload
anything right
so I say to the guy he goes oh yeah he
said you ordered the truck when did you
order it
I said because I said it's coming this
month or next month he goes when did you
order it and I was like uh last summer
he goes yeah good luck with that if you
look if you view that dude it's like all
right buddy thank you happy [ __ ] New
Year
well you're literally [ __ ] on your
own goddamn company insubordination
um
[ __ ] annoying
but anyways the truck is coming I can't
[ __ ] wait and um
I don't know if I didn't have kids I
would get rid of my my other my uh my
daily driver there
um 17 year olds
thoughts on my generation
all right you must be your older
generation yo Bill I'm 17 years old
oh yo your thoughts on your generation
I think the stigma that my generation
and the one just a bit older than me
being lazy is somewhat accurate but not
a complete rule of thumb
all right I'm going to be a [ __ ] here
and give you my theory
I think because old people can go on the
internet and talk about younger
Generations rather than just doing it
down the barbershop like they used to
there's a lot more chatter out there
um
how could you be lazier than Generation
X what am I is that what I was
Gen X yeah
it's so funny now like I watch these
things these things and they act like
Generation X people worked
like our generation worked and like
When We Were Young they called us the
slacker generation and then somehow the
generation that called us the slacker
generation I think died over the last 30
years so now we get to rewrite our
history like now we were these
hard-working people that rolled up our
sleeves I mean some of us were
I don't know anyway
um this person says I think the reason
that kids my age are lazy is because
everything is so automatic my dad owns a
blue-collar business and my mom is a
lawyer so I grew up understanding the
importance of both
of what blue collar and white collar
I'll be in class I like your dad man
married up good deal I'll be in a class
or the lunchroom and the disdain that my
peers have for any job below guy who
tells people what to do is off the
charts
is that right
well maybe it's because you guys also
are on like social media and everybody
has to sit there and act like they have
a bunch of money and
they're killing it and living their best
life anyway having a blue collar dad I
never looked at the janitors or the
plumbers as morons
uh someone needs to fix the [ __ ]
toilets Bill exactly I'm not saying that
making fun of Plumbing as a job is a big
deal
dude if you if plumber that's a [ __ ]
great job and an unbelievable skill
to know how to do
I mean every [ __ ] three months I have
to remind myself where the main water
shut off is
it's the easiest run outside the house
and just week week you know Lefty Loosey
righty tighty right I I [ __ ]
have all I can do to [ __ ] do that and
these guys can go in there
and redo your whole house if you want
dude
Carpenters
plumbers
electricians mechanics
you know those [ __ ] uh Geek Squad
people that can fix your computers like
I have a tremendous respect for all of
those people
those bootleg cell phone places
that'll fix your IPhone screen and all
of that [ __ ]
oh there goes your warranty I go [ __ ]
yourselves you Apple [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] I love anybody that can fix
[ __ ] anything
I mean that like the level of respect
that I haven't had the fascination that
I have with all of that I just think
it's amazing
you know and then not to mention the
sense of satisfaction you get when you
go in there's a problem and you go in
and you fix it
I mean I get that when I you know I walk
around the house replacing all the the
track lighting that [ __ ] burned out
you know I just replaced the battery in
in the garage door opener
I I get a little lift I feel a little
taller that day when I do that I can't
imagine
if I went under the [ __ ] sink changed
out a j-trap I used to know how to do
that
I don't do that [ __ ] anymore I actually
when I used to rented this [ __ ]
apartment
all of that [ __ ]
I learned how to do uh basic repairs
with that [ __ ] in the uh that plumber's
tape and all of that got myself a big
[ __ ] monkey wrench and all of that I
got underneath there I cleaned I used to
clean it out if uh
my wife dropped something down there or
got like clogged up that's what I do I
got under the sink I take out the whole
j-trap I wouldn't snake it out
you know because I didn't know how to
use a snake I would literally take the
whole thing apart and just take a
screwdriver down there and then years
later I was just like or I could have
just learned how to [ __ ] learn
how to snake the thing out you know you
know what I do now I just call
Roto-Rooter that's the name and Away Go
Your Troubles Down the Drain
um
I think all of that shit's cabin tree
you know electrician I mean to me you're
basically a wizard
I don't know how the [ __ ] you do that
stuff without killing yourself
um anyway
uh having a blue collar dad I never
looked down again okay someone needs to
fix the toilet spill I'm not saying
making fun of Plumbing as a job is a big
deal but the end of the day most of my
friends wouldn't even dare to try to
understand how to do anything of the
sort
I wonder if there's going to be like a
plumbing shortage I remember my whole
time growing up there would be periods
where uh my mom was a nurse they would
be like nurse shortages
and um
because like for whatever reason they
would just go through periods of like
okay we need to pay nurses all right we
got enough we're not paying them [ __ ]
and then women be like well [ __ ] that
job okay we need nurses we go back and
forth like uh that whole debate about
whether an egg is good for you or not
um anyway one time I helped a girl jump
her car in the parking lot and instead
of thanking me she turned around and
laughed then said under her breath
um why does he know how to do this
I wanted to cut that twat's brake line
right then and there
oh right there and then is how you say
she said that after you helped her out
you know what that's probably because
she feels dumb or she was with some dude
that didn't know how to do it
um
I'll be honest with you I gotta remember
how to do that I always forget do you
hook it up to the dead battery first or
the live
I mean positive is positive I mean
that's easy
and then you also got a uh ground it
right you got to clip it on the side
you know what my big thing that I really
knew how to do when I could [ __ ] do
it in two seconds
was change a tire
as like a comedian on the [ __ ] road
and you'd get a flat on the [ __ ]
driver's side on the [ __ ] highway
oh my God I had a piece of pipe
like [ __ ] three feet long
four feet long right behind my the bench
seat of my truck
and I remember getting and I had like in
my spare tire I had it in my bed I
didn't have it underneath where it gets
all you know back East that whole
assembly would get all rusted and you
couldn't get the [ __ ] thing off if
you wanted to
um I had that in the bed of my truck
until one night somebody [ __ ] stole
it but I had it like ready to go
and I would [ __ ] get out of the truck
that little [ __ ] [ __ ] ass j-bar
thing that they would give you that you
get no [ __ ] leverage on I put the
[ __ ]
four foot pipe on it and just bang
bang get them all off while it was still
on the ground
which is what you want to do you loosen
it when it's on the ground so either the
[ __ ] thing doesn't spin or something
like that then I would Jack the [ __ ]
up take it off put it I would have the
[ __ ] lug nuts in the bed of the truck
put it back on [ __ ] give it a yank
and I would be back in I could literally
change the thing I had it changed in
like under [ __ ] uh
like five minutes
like I got to the point I didn't even
have hubcaps on my truck because you
know you needed like a Phillips
screwdriver to take the [ __ ] things
off and I was just like I'm not dealing
with that on the side of a goddamn Road
where I could get clipped
and I still remember coming back to rest
his soul one of those dick Doherty gigs
and like Drake it or Manchester New
Hampshire and I got a flat tire
it was left rear
driver's side
and dude I was I I pulled like halfway
off I was in the emergency Lane and I
put two tires on the grass and I was
still changing that thing and these
feeling the cars going by and you know
when that wind hits you the lower part
of your pant legs down by your calves
and make some stick to your shin and I
was just sitting there going like please
I never been so [ __ ] scared of my
life
um
and that was just that
and knowing how to change the oil and
the oil filter air filter fuel filter I
got myself to be I was really good at
the outskirts I never had the balls to
get into uh
gapping a spark plug and the timing belt
and all of that type of distributor cap
all of that [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of
me but um
I think knowing how to do that stuff is
the is the coolest [ __ ] ever
um
I don't know I'm really going down
memory Memory Lane here
so look I feel good like I said if I
change the battery on a goddamn garage
door opener or if I change a tire I feel
like a [ __ ] man I can't imagine if
you actually know how to
plum
be an electrician or a carpenter all
right bill you made the Goddamn point
um why does he even know how to do this
you're welcome [ __ ] anyway I think part
of the problem is that we're told we're
all told to just keep our heads down and
get into a good college my uncle
explained to me that College tuition can
be unreasonably increased all the time
because there's no limit to the loan
amounts that we can have he's the one
who introduced me to your comedy and
podcast oh
tell him I said thank you my cousin
graduated with 165 000 in debt and a
degree in sociology I asked him what he
was going to do with it when he was a
junior in his junior year and he had no
clue it was at a holiday gathering over
dinner my response in front of everyone
was don't expect me to support you when
you have no job
I said it like a parent would in a fake
Stern voice
I was thinking I was thinking I was
being funny he did not neither did his
parents
yeah because they're the ones that are
on the hook for it I think it's funny
that all my friends all my all my
friends do is blame Boomers and gen xers
for all the problems of the world then
turn to them as if to say how could you
steer me wrong man uh to sum it all up I
think there are many reasons my
generation is or can seem lazy some of
it is their fault some of it isn't
that's the truest thing ever
and some of the problems of today are
because of Boomers and gen xers and some
of it isn't
um it's more like uh where you're at
right now
where you're sort of young and you're
standing on the banks of the Rushing
River and at some point you got to jump
in and try and swim
and the deal is what the deal is you
know
I think everybody young is like yeah
we're gonna change this [ __ ]
and
I think that's the genius of a college
education is it gets you so [ __ ]
behind the eight ball with the debt that
you don't have time to question the
Ponzi scheme and you're like [ __ ] it I
gotta play or I'm gonna go under I'm
gonna be one of these people living in a
tent city under a [ __ ] Bridge
um well that's depressing
um
yeah uh
I don't you know as much as I [ __ ]
about [ __ ] I don't look down on younger
people or that type of [ __ ] uh I do make
fun of you though which is the right of
being an older person and
all you guys can just say is like well
you know you're gonna die before me and
then you win all right underrated
everybody uh the week between Christmas
and New Year's
it's the best week of the year if you
were blessed enough to have gifts at
Christmas time you had all week to play
with them video games and snow on the
ground was the perfect combination for
me as a child in the late 80s and early
90s
wow I literally smelt the cold air when
you just said that that was the best
pond hockey
pond hockey between [ __ ] Christmas
and New Year's if it wasn't too [ __ ]
cold was [ __ ] amazing
why did that just take me back to that
anyway you go outside play in the snow
come back in and crowd around the Sega
Genesis
occasionally I'd actually read a book
that's [ __ ] amazing
um anyway all right that is the podcast
look at this did an hour and nine
minutes you can tell look at me I'm back
no more pneumonia
um all right here's to a great year hope
you guys all have uh happiness and
health I hope you go after what you want
to go after this year
you know say hello to the pretty girl do
whatever the [ __ ] it is that you you
haven't been doing and
um
you know don't be a [ __ ]
and I don't know
do your part to try to help get us out
of this mess
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday